Доброго дня!
Вас вітає київський охоронний патруль, дядьку.
Що ви тут порушуєте? Скільки вам років взагалі? Що ви тут займаєтесь дурницями?..
Я її просто випустив!
Це звична реакція рибалок при наближенні човна рибоохорони - випускати рибу у воду.
Судак, якого зловив цей дідусь, одразу спливає і дістається чайкам.
Інспектори дістають рибу з води і з'ясовують, що її не більше, ніж дозволено законом.
- Давайте нам мішок - заберіть рибу.
- Не треба мені риби! То не моя!
З жовтня майже в 200 разів в Україні зросли штрафи за незаконний вилов риби.
Не можна ловити на знаряддя, яке калічить рибу, а маленькі особини слід відпускати назад у водойму.
На одного рибалку в день дозволено виловлювати три кілограми риби.
Якщо ж зловили зайве - доведеться платити: за кожного наступного карася півтори тисячі гривень, за судака - три з половиною.
Найдорожче обійдеться вам сом - понад 5 тисяч гривень.
І навіть за зайвого рака рибінспекція може виписати штраф у розмірі майже три з половиною тисячі гривень.
Робота наша полягає в тому, що ми контролюємо правила любительського і спортивного рибальства.
Дивимося, щоби люди не порушували. Якщо порушують - складаємо відповідно адмінматеріали.
Слідкувати за порушниками на воді в Україні довірено двом структурам: водній поліції або рибоохоронному патрулю.
До його рейду поблизу Вишгорода доєдналася DW.
Якщо він рибу вже викинув, то ми нічого вже не зробимо. Абсолютно. Рибка просто собі попливе!
Рибалки-любителі штрафам не раді, але визнають, що галузь все одно реформувати треба. Особливо не люблять тут тих, хто нищить рибу.
Сітки я б взагалі розстрілював! Чесно! Я вважаю, що треба робити як у нормальних країнах - запроваджувати ліцензію.
Ти купуєш ліцензію і маєш право взяти певну кількість риби, але якщо ти вже ці правила порушиш, тоді карати безбожно!
Згідно з постановою уряду України, нові дорогі тарифи - це компенсація завданих державі збитків.
Рибінспекція лише фіксує порушення і виписує протокол.
До 100 тисяч - адміністративний, а після - вже наступає кримінальна відповідальність.
Якщо у суді вина рибалки буде доведена - кошти підуть у бюджет громади.
Щоправда, експерти і чиновник  не виключають, що такі високі штрафи можуть створити підґрунтя для нових корупційних схем.
У середньому інспектор отримує від 10 до 15 тисяч гривень. Але це ніяк не міняє ситуацію.
Оскільки занадто мала зарплата у зв'язку з підвищенням такс може створити нові корупційні ризики.
Охочих охороняти українські річки менше, ніж тих, хто заробляє на життя браконьєрством.
Наприклад, на всю Київську область - 60 патрульних.
А на транспорт і катери держава виділяє 80 літрів бензину.
- Як рибалка?
- Та нічого, потихеньку...
Брак ресурсу в рибоохороні частково закривають активісти, які самі зголошуються інспектувати водойми.
Як-от "Річковий дозор" - громадська організація, яку 5 років тому створив Юрій Дозор.
Тоді він був простим рибалкою, який зрозумів: аби без докорів сумління ловити рибу на вудку, слід спершу захистити її від браконьєрів.
Це повністю політика! Якщо нас змушують їсти рибу чужої країни, а наша риба йде на якісь консерви, в чому прикол?
Я не можу зрозуміти. Чому я маю їсти польського карпа? Чи якогось там китайського судака? Якщо у мене в моїй країні це все є?
У моїй країні є все, що мені потрібно для життя, а мене привчають їсти чуже! А я не хочу! Я хочу їсти своє!
Активіст розповідає, що в Україні є своя рибна мафія і що він за свої спроби втрутитися у їхній бізнес кілька разів отримував погрози.
Юрій переконаний, що ситуацію може вирішити тільки докорінна реформа галузі.
Я вважаю, що злочинами на воді мають займатися поліцейські, а не рибоохорона.
Рибоохорона має регулювати всі ці рухи, але це не їхня парафія. Абсолютно. У них навіть пістолета немає.
Тобто їм складно конкурувати з бандитом. А в бандита завжди все є.
- Рибу ловлять бандити?
- Ну, він же вчиняє злочин? Значить бандит!
Треба насамперед перевіряти ті човни, де один рибалка, бо якщо їх більше, тоді здобич ділиться на два - ділиться лайфхаком інспектор.
І ось - на наступному човні зустрічаємо рибалку, який за кілька годин встиг наловити 40 судаків, а це на 10 кілограмів більше за норму.
Це у вас адмінка, це простіше. Зловили б ви ще три судачки і мали би вже кримінальну справу. Вилучили б човен, і все.
Чоловік стверджує: про нові розцінки не знав, а рибалка так добре йшла, що він і не зауважив, скільки вже рибин кинув у сітку.
Тепер йому доведеться заплатити 640 гривень штрафу одразу і 100 тисяч гривень збитку після рішення суду.
Принаймні нове джерело поповнення місцевих бюджетів дає громадам фінансову можливість
для створення нових туристичних маршрутів для рибалок-любителів.
А це у свою чергу означає створення нових робочих місць для тих, хто досі не бачив іншого способу заробітку, окрім браконьєрства.
Тому що браконьєрство - це як корупція, залежить від соціально-економічного благополуччя населення.
Подорожчання штрафів за незаконну риболовлю не повинно вплинути на ціну риби в супермаркеті,
оскільки майже вся вона імпортована з Польщі чи Китаю.
Водночас нові розцінки можуть стати відчутними для тих, хто звик купувати рибу на ринку, куди зазвичай здають свою здобич браконьєри.